IGNACIO MONEREO:
So hi, everyone.
I'm Ignacio, or Nacho.
I am based in London, and I
work with many game developers
across the Western
Europe region.
So many of you-- in fact, I
see a lot of familiar faces.
So thanks for coming
after the break.
Thanks for being here.
And today, we're going to
talk about old games, which
in some cases, in
some instances,
might be your first success.
And we are going to
understand whether these,
they age better or worse.
And the goal of this
session is basically--
whoa, that was a
strong introduction.
So the goal of this
session is essentially
to understand, what are
the different strategies?
So if these games are becoming
a burden or a technology debt
or if these are actually
the new opportunity
that you can actually follow.
And to do that, I will have on
stage two fantastic speakers,
so Erik, CEO of
Dodreams, and, as well,
Anette, VP of Business and
Marketing from Dirtybit.
So I wanted to start
with a very easy example.
Because when we're thinking
about old games, then
I thought, all right,
let's look at old games
and how they look like today.
So we have two games
here, both of them
by the Russian
developer Game Insight.
I don't know if you're
familiar with them,
but "Tribez" was published
six years ago in 2012.
And we have, as well, "Transport
Empire," published in 2014
four years ago.
And there is a big difference
among these developers.
I don't know if
maybe you can guess.
If you are obviously working for
Game Insights, you would know.
OK, so I'm just going to--
so essentially, what
happens with these games
is that one of these games
is actually a priority today.
Still it represents a
big part of the revenues.
So when I was
looking at old games,
we basically identified that
some of these old games, they
became an evergreen title.
And even though it's been a long
time since they were published,
they still represent a
very important source
of revenues for the developer.
And as well, this translates
into having these resources
into the game.
And "Transport Empire" would
be part of that back catalog.
So the first thing to
consider is this one.
If we look at another
two examples here,
both of them, in this
case, are top priorities
for both developers.
However, if we look
at the right side,
we might think that this
game is-- it looks classier
or at least slightly older.
And in fact, "RuneScape
Old School" by Jagex
was published in PC for the
first time 17 years ago,
so it makes sense.
While "Respawnables,"
Digital Legends,
was published five
years ago only.
However, if you are a fan
of "RuneScape Old School,"
you would know that the game
hasn't been launched yet
in mobile.
It's in fact, launching in two
weeks, the 2nd of November.
So when we are talking
about, why is a game old,
or how is an old game--
how do we define these?
Is it by the launch
date, by when
the game was released in PC,
in the case of "RuneScape?"
Or maybe it's just one year,
five years, or two years.
So this is two things that
we need to have in mind,
and then we were trying to
figure out how these games are
performing nowadays in Play.
And we had to take
two assumptions, which
are very big assumptions.
And the first case was when
the game was published.
And so we are going to
look at games that were
published four years or older.
And then also if this game
represents a top priority
for the company--
if the game is driving
most of the revenues,
then in this case, we
will consider an outlier.
So we're making the
assumption of less than 50%
of the overall portfolio
of the developer.
So if we look at these and
we take these into account,
and we look at the top games
by revenue and downloads
in the Play Store, we will see
that, in fact, old games are
very much alive and kicking.
And what it means is that--
so first of all, old games--
these games with these four
years old and, as well,
less than 50%--
they represent 17%
of those top revenue
games in the Play Store.
And as well, they receive
new users every day.
17.5% of the downloads
in the past six months
were going to these titles.
From an engagement perspective,
it's something similar.
We see that these
old games-- they
seem to have very engaged
communities and fans that they
keep playing and, on average,
59% of daily active users
more than the newer games.
On the other hand, the
design of the games-- it
seems to be shorter
[? terms, ?] so shorter times.
And we see that,
on average, they
spend less time per daily
active users, so 29% less.
Also, we take into
account monetization,
within-app purchases.
In particular, we will
see that old games,
they tend to monetize
slightly less better.
And we see minus 18% in ARPDAU.
And last but not least, as
everything old in this life,
it tends to have some issues.
We see that, also, from
a vitals perspective,
they have, on average, 50% more
crash rates and 20% more ANRs.
So in a nutshell, these games,
these four-year-old games,
they have a lot of
new fresh installs,
new users coming every day.
They still make a lot
of significant revenue,
although might be
slightly lower.
And they have some issues
in terms of, for example,
vitals and crash rates and ANRs.
Now, the question here
is, is this a burden?
Do we consider these
games as technology debt,
or do we consider
it an opportunity?
And so there's two
very clear ways,
but there is three routes.
So there's three common ways
that developers are following.
So if you go to the very much
I consider this as a burden,
the ultimate case is
to unpublish the game.
And this is the
case that we will
hear from Dirtybit later on.
If you go on the
other hand, I consider
this as my biggest
opportunity, then why not
I put more resources into
this game and try to revamp it
and become again one of
my top drivers of revenue?
And this is the case
from Dodreams later on.
And when we ask developers, we
found out that majority of you,
that you go into what we
call the back catalog mode
or long tail or status quo.
And so we ask, how do
games end up in this mode?
So there's a couple
of common factors.
So many times, we see that
LiveOps, new content updates--
they don't have the same effect.
As well, the ROI campaigns,
they try to stabilize.
LTV is very similar to CPIs.
Other factors could
be also affecting,
for example, cannibalization
between your own games.
You launch a new game,
and you see a lot of users
from the previous one
go into this title
and, as well, external
factors, such as competitors
or new genres that
are appearing.
And does this mean
that the game is dead?
Well actually, no,
and that's for sure.
We still have very
engaged communities.
And as Game Insights
was sharing with us,
brand perception is very
important, and keeping alive
this game is critical for them.
But also, generally,
they're very profitable.
So if we look at the games
[? instance ?] as well,
we see that old games,
or long-tail games,
generate 14% of
the total revenues.
And on average, they
have 50% more profits
than the newer ones.
So what are the key challenges?
So I put three key challenges.
There might be more.
But the main ones would be
first is spaghetti code.
So some problems with
the-- as the case
we've seen that they have some
issues with technical problems
like ANRs and crash rates.
Also as well, monetization
is hard to keep up
with the [? CPNs ?] updating
the mediation platforms as well.
Sometimes you might
see that your game
is using agencies that
they do not [INAUDIBLE]
or networks that
they are not anymore.
And last, team.
Every developer
is looking forward
to work in the next title,
in the next big hit.
And convincing then, motivating
the users or the developers
to actually work in these
games might be hard.
So just to finalize this,
some very few recommendations
from another developer here
today with us, Oh BiBi.
So we have-- to tackle
these precise challenges,
we can think about the ways
to optimize a target SDK,
how we can keep updating
the game or the versions
of the engine in a efficient
way, maybe outsourcing.
Another way, also,
of thinking is,
how do we keep an
efficient monetization
by updating automatically
the CPMs or by,
for example, automatizing
the customer support
whenever the players are
using in-app purchases?
Another very interesting
example, automatizing LiveOps.
So for example, the Halloween
sales or the Halloween LiveOps
that you are running
this year might
be the same as the last year.
But users, they might not know.
The players might not know
that this is exactly the same,
and that keeps the
game fresh and alive.
And last but not least, we've
seen today a number of examples
of how can you improve your
conversion via store listings,
for example, country targeting.
We have it now.
And this will help you to
drive and continue driving
those users to your game.
And with this, I would
like to invite to the stage
Anette Staloy, who
is going to talk
about a different way,
which is, in this case,
to actually go unpublishing.
ANETTE STALOY: Thank you.
IGNACIO MONEREO: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ANETTE STALOY: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
It's my first time
at the Playtime event
and my first time
in Berlin, actually.
So I joined the games industry
in the Norwegian studio
called Dirtybit three years ago.
And I work in the
management team
together with the founders.
So working for a
small company means
that I work with both
management, business
development, marketing, ad ops.
Dirtybit was founded
in 2011, and I've
been part of the
company since we were
8 and to a team of 18 today.
We're based in Bergen on
the west coast of Norway.
Anyone who has been
in Bergen here?
Oh, quite a few, cool.
So we're owned by the founders.
And us employees, we make and
publish free-to-play games,
and we monetize on
in-app purchase and ads.
Two of the founders grew
up together in Bergen,
and they had many fond
memories of beating
each other in "Mario Kart."
So when they started
making games,
they could find a lot
of multiplayer games,
but they were all turn-based.
So they took on the challenge of
making a real-time multiplayer
game.
And remember, this was in
2011, so this was quite unique
at the time.
This is how it looked.
Have anyone played it?
Nice.
So the game started spreading
in schools in the US,
and it went viral
in social media.
It trended on Twitter, and
it reached the top charts
overall in the US and many
other countries-- not bad
for a very small,
young team from Norway.
So in April this year,
we had three games live,
all in the "Fun Run" series.
As you can see,
"Fun Run" that was
launched in 2012,
the next one in 2014.
So even if we had
all these games live,
all games were still
getting downloads
and had significant user bases.
But most of our
efforts were into what
I call the new game, which
was launched in 2016.
So what we saw was that even if
it brings most of our revenue,
it only gets about
half of our downloads.
So fast-forwarding a few months,
this is how it looks today.
So now we can see that
the new game, newest game,
has more than 99%
of our downloads
and is also bringing
in most of the revenue.
So what happened?
Last year, our current
strategy, as it
had been for several years,
was to grow the user base.
And we actually reached
100 million downloads,
all organic, no paid UA.
That's pretty cool, right?
So as our network in the
industry grew and many of you
started sharing numbers with
us and we got a little help
from app [INAUDIBLE]
premium, we realized
that we had a lot to improve
when it comes to monetization.
We hired a full-time
analyst, and that
helped us transitioning from
basing most of our decisions
on gut feeling to really
diving into the numbers.
We started doing some UA,
and it became more clear
that we need a new strategy
to increase our revenue.
So that's what we've
been doing this year is
focusing on the numbers,
analyzing everything.
And our analyst introduced this
term of MMM, Making More Money.
Maybe you do that
the same as well.
We have been very
careful, scared
of harming the user experience.
So we have been trying to
enhance our monetization,
and it's been well-received.
And everybody's happy.
The analyst is happy,
and we're happy.
We've been working
more focused with ASO,
and I brought this example here.
When we first launched
"Fun Run 3 Arena,"
we didn't even call
it "Fun Run 3."
We called it "Fun Run Arena"
because our gut feeling said
that that was the
right thing to do.
So this was the icon,
also based on gut feeling.
A year after launch,
we did an experiment
in Google Play just
adding the number 3.
And as you can see the
results, it became clear to us
that we should update both
the title and the icon.
So "Fun Run 3" was
clearly our star.
But what's the challenge?
The monetization,
when we compared it
to the older titles, two to
four times better ARPDAU.
Retention was
clearly a lot better.
Technology-- we
built the newest game
in Unity, which made it
easier for us to maintain.
This is the game where
we had the dedicated team
and want to deliver the
best gameplay and best user
experience.
And I know that
Nacho and [INAUDIBLE]
if you have seen their
talks before, you
might have heard
them talking about we
live in a post-launch world.
And we agree, and we
plan to do LiveOps
for this game to
improve it, make
it even better for a long time.
So the challenges, as
can see from some numbers
from AppAnnie showing our
most important keyword.
The users searching for our
game found the old titles,
and they were a bit confused
it seemed to what to download.
We even got a big
featuring for "Fun Run 2,"
and thank you very much.
We appreciate that, but it
didn't help us grow "Fun Run 3"
We tried to un-optimize.
I don't know if you've tried it.
It can be pretty tricky when
you have millions of downloads
with a lot of historical data.
When we launched "Fun Run 1"
and 2, we had organic growth.
The games went viral,
hit the top charts.
We couldn't do that the same.
And we were competing not
only with all the games
in the market but
also ourselves.
So here, you can
see what happened
when we started testing
removing "Fun Run 1" from Turkey
where we had a
significant user base.
People started downloading
"Fun Run 2," not "Fun Run 3."
So when we removed "Fun
Run 2" from the market,
finally people were starting to
download "Fun Run 3" as well.
And it started to grow.
So we decided to unpublish,
like Nacho talked about.
We saw from the test that
we expected the new game
to absorb 90% of the downloads.
"Fun Run 3" was the game we
wanted our users to download.
The monetization was better.
We wanted to be open
with our community
and inform them
that we were going
to focus on "Fun Run
3" going forward,
and we expected a backlash.
We were right.
"Fun Run 3" absorbed
most of the downloads,
and it's been growing since.
So we increased our user
base in "Fun Run 3."
Overall, we lost
users, but that was
because we removed older games.
We managed to
increase our revenue.
This is from April to August.
And August and
September has been
looking pretty nice as well.
We have been able
to free up resources
to do the great LiveOps we
want to do for "Fun Run 3."
So our key learnings is
we tested in a market
where we had a
significant user base.
We knew what
numbers to look for,
and we made decisions
based on the key metrics.
And we were prepared to
let the first game go
even if there is a lot of
nostalgia there as well.
We planned for the best and
the worst-case scenario,
and we had a plan B.
Do not underestimate
the impact on your community.
And I brought this example
today because we still
have a very active
"Fun Run 2" community.
They even made a petition to
make us bring the game back.
Every time we post
something in social media,
like I did today from
here, first reply
is, please remember "Fun Run 2."
And they made a very
touching video with music.
So this happens every time.
So even though
some of our players
rated "Fun Run 3" with
one star because they
want us to bring them back, we
have a very active community
playing "Fun Run 3,"
creating content, and helping
us grow organically.
So for us, the right
decision was to divest.
So I have the honor of
inviting my good friend, Erik,
to the stage to talk
about their approach,
which was a bit different.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIK PONTISKOSKI: [INAUDIBLE].
ANETTE STALOY: There you are.
ERIK PONTISKOSKI:
Thank you very much.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Erik, and
I'm the CEO at Dodreams.
It's really exciting to be
here in Berlin at Playtime
and honor to share the stage
with my dear friends, Nacho
and Anette.
I will present today or talk
about our portfolio strategy.
I will present what
kind of choices we made,
explain what was the logic
behind those choices,
and then present what kind of
impact it had on our business.
At Dodreams, we make games
where players do stuff
that dreams are made of.
So we are Dodreams.
And we are the makers of
this "Drive Ahead!" portfolio
of games.
This key art is for
our game "Drive Ahead!"
"Drive Ahead!" is a
gladiator car fight game.
what that means
is you get points
by hitting your friend
in the head with a car.
And thank you for that
reaction because that's
what 100 million people
all around the world
think also when they decided
to download the game.
So it's a really fun
and simple premise.
And in our vision,
"Drive Ahead!" games
are the best way to play, share,
and watch fun gaming content.
So we have a very large
and active community built
around video for the game.
And thanks to this
community, we're
getting 100,000 new
downloads every single day.
And this is what the game
originally looked like.
So it was developed for a sauna
party by one of our employees.
So he was having some
beers with his friends,
and they came up
with this idea that,
hey, what would it look
like if a tank would
be battling a lorry truck?
And let's put a
garbage truck there
against a go-kart or
something like that.
So even today, the game
looks pretty much the same.
In the core gameplay,
of course, we've
brought a lot of
other stuff to it.
So the first game
went live in 2015.
And then in 2016, we decided
that, let's have a portfolio
strategy.
Business logic there is that
we'll do cross promotion,
we're going to get the higher
number of daily active users,
and then we're going
to make more money.
And then also, we had
realized that when
we made the first game, maybe
we weren't so experienced
or we made some mistakes.
So instead of going
through the trouble
of updating the first game,
let's just fix everything
that we did wrong at one go.
And we were quite
experimental with it.
So we decided that instead of
just making the second game,
let's experiment a little bit.
So we had an idea
for "Drive Ahead!
Sports," so you can play soccer
and other sports with cars.
So we made it first an
event in the original game.
And when we told fans
that summer is over,
soccer is going away,
then they started
begging us to bring it back.
And we said, well,
you can play it.
But it's going to be
a standalone game.
And in 2016, actually it
had significant contribution
to the studio revenue.
In 2017, we realized that
this portfolio approach
isn't working perfectly for us.
So "Drive Ahead!
Sports" turned out to
be even more a skill
game than the
original game, so it's
reaching a more niche audience.
We were able to be better
in the free-to-play design
of the game.
So for example, ARPDAU
was 2.5 times higher.
But that doesn't really help
when you're reaching only 20%
of the players from
the original title.
And the really ugly
thing we did in 2017
was that we tried
to fix everything
once again at one go.
So we made a major
change where changed
the UI, UX, added a saga
map, and tons of other thing.
And everybody hated it.
So we lost half of the
players and revenue,
and retention was
almost destroyed
and nearly killed the game.
And then we also
went all in with AR.
So we made a game
called "Drive Ahead!
Minigolf."
So if we have car
gladiators, this
is what they do in
their free time.
And it turned out that we were
there a little bit too early
and were doing fancy motion
controls with the device.
People were playing
minigolf like this,
and it didn't work out either.
So we discovered that this is
a bit risky as an approach.
So the decision was that let's
focus on the original title.
It's getting that 100,000
new players a day.
Good things are that there's
high engagement and virality
through the community.
We realized that
we've only scratched
the surface with
monetization potential there.
So that's a picture of our team
there with our head of studio
talking to them.
And this is the group
that was given the task
to revamp the game.
Our approach was the following.
We realized that it's
too much risk changing
things in the game, like
making too big changes.
But we had started
doing LiveOps,
which is a really great place
to change the rules of the game.
And we see what
works there and then
bring it into the actual game.
And so what happened
next was that we
started doing these iterations.
So first, we redid the
first-time user experience
to teach the players how to
watch ads as a daily habit
and show the value of growing
your collection in the game.
And then in the second iteration
was our LiveOps events,
where we gave the
players the feature
that they could
build a deck of cars
that they use in a boss fight.
So both experiments increased
ad engagement rate by 50%,
and ad engagement is
one of our key KPIs.
So the lessons we
learned here was
that when you launch a
new game in a portfolio,
you have to very
clearly define, what
is the positioning
of that product,
and why should it exist
as a standalone game?
And what has worked
really well for us
is validating new
features, content, even
new games with the community.
We found that when we
openly say that this
is the good stuff
of our game and this
is what we're trying
to fix, it actually
attracts new talent,
then, and ignites
the passion of the team.
So we've had really senior
people join the studio
because they say that the
problems you guys have
are fun problems to solve.
So let's fix monetization
when you have a big community.
And you might wonder what
happened to "Drive Ahead!
Sports."
So we still have it live.
We empowered a fresh,
young, talented team
to take ownership of the game.
And they're doing
a really good job
and really battling against
the "Drive Ahead!" team.
So that's all for me.
So now I'd like
to invite Nacho--
[STUTTERS] Mr. Money
Oreo back on the stage
to do his conclusions.
IGNACIO MONEREO: Thank
you, Mr. Pontiskoski.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so to
conclude, I'm going
to take a couple [INAUDIBLE].
So first of all, remind that--
and this is a quote from Erik,
in fact, which is if a player
has downloaded the game and is
a new player, he doesn't know--
or he or she doesn't
know that the game
was published five years ago.
So this is something really
important to remember,
to keep it fresh and
have that in mind.
And so just to
conclude, so we've
seen that old games still
receive a big number
of downloads nowadays.
So this is incredibly
interesting for you
to think about, like, how
do you explore and to test?
Also that they have
engaged communities
and then they can
be very profitable.
So what you can do, and I
think some of the insights
that we've learned--
so first of all, take
decisions based on metrics
and be ready to let the
first success, your baby, go.
Well, that was the
case of Dirtybit.
As well, consider the community.
We've seen that the community
always is going to be a problem
or is going to
react in some way.
So how do you plan
before unpublishing
if you take that route?
And if you decide
to revamp the game,
I think Erik mentioned
some managerial lessons,
his insights on his experience
with exciting the team,
motivating the developers in
order to really work together
to grow the game again.
And with this,
thank you very much.